estos son los contenedores donde están
almacenados las dosis de la vacuna de
facer variante contra el coi 19 programa
este sábado empezaron a ser repartidas
en varias ciudades francesas a un día de
la fecha anunciada por la unión europea
para iniciar su campaña de inmunización
en total tenemos 19 mil 500 dosis estas
vacunas están almacenadas en nuestro
congelador a 80 grados bajo cero
y luego serán distribuidas a los
diferentes hogares para ancianos y
hospitales públicos legalmente
previamente cerca de diez mil dosis
llegaron a roma la capital italiana y
atenas la capital griega
hay un plan organizado para que podamos
ganarle la batalla a esta pandemia y
retomar nuestras vidas
y mágicas pandemias en rumanía las
autoridades aseguraron que es necesario
mantener la confianza en el fármaco como
una esperanza para superar la crisis de
una necesidad y montán a rafa que hemos
estado esperando por este momento todo
el año la entrega y distribución de la
vacuna en tiempo récord ayudará a
limitar y erradicar la pandemia en poco
tiempo si se siguen las medidas que ya
hemos implementado a limitar así la
la vacuna the fighter by and text fue
aprobada por la comisión europea el
pasado 21 de diciembre tras la
recomendación de la agencia europea de
medicamentos que autorizó aplicar el
fármaco a personas mayores de 16 años
los adultos mayores y el personal
sanitario son los grupos prioritarios de
la campaña cuando el continente supera
los 25 millones de positivos